so we already talked about the visibly
sweaty and orange donald trump
a bla bragging to a colorado springs
crowd about his followers
essentially being cultists i want to
take a few minutes now
to mention more generally that at that
same rally in colorado springs
and at the following one that he did in
las vegas nevada
donald trump looked and sounded more
unwell than we've seen in a really
long time and the things he was saying
were concerning
the way he looked was concerning and the
way he sounded was concerning and
people are noticing the international
business times reported
trump reportedly looks bad at vegas
rally
potus suffering from mental physical
decline
a number of other articles asked
essentially the same questions
let's look at some examples from two
events again it's the colorado springs
rally
and then a las vegas rally trump again
visibly
sweaty very red upper trump in colorado
springs
downer trump in las vegas maybe trump
arriving
sort of late east coast time for the
colorado springs rally maybe needed a
little something to get him going for
that one
wouldn't be surprising if he was giving
himself a boost with something
check out trump unable to read his
teleprompter
in the context that the speech is
written
slurring about the rocky mountains
making no syntactical sense here
beautiful place beneath the majestic
peaks that's true
of the rocky mountains with thousands of
terrific
hard-working great american patriots
trump then started wildly reading
totally
out of context numbers with no
reasonable inflection where you can even
understand what on earth this guy is
talking about
look at this look at this trump 70
next one is 18 next one is seven
four three three three
two one one one
trump didn't do well in the debates see
they're fake news
then trump slurring and attacking
someone
not exactly sure who is this now i feel
good
now i feel good
she's a third-rate journalist let's go
we're standing up
in defense of our constitution and then
trump started mixing up conflicting
conspiracy theories which was really
weird
try to understand this and look at how
he takes like two or three words
from different conspiracy theories and
you know we're working with the cloud
we're working with these people they
want to take you out
they want to change the results they got
caught
spying let's say it like it is right
they got caught
spying on our election fake news hey
fake news
take your cameras for a change and show
them the room
and show them behind you
the cloud spying fake news election like
it's completely dissembling in front of
our very eyes
then he starts talking about mayor pete
and i guess now he's referring to
to mayor pete as buddha touch
buddha touch listen to this alfred
newman buddhich little buddha touch
i said i've had you up to here they had
little buddhists
leading donald trump in texas these
people
but very close he said it's too close to
call this is a poll
where buddhist edge so a friend of mine
from texas is a big powerful strong guy
real texas he's got the cowboy hat i'd
love to wear that
i wouldn't have to coat my hair so much
i wouldn't need hairspray right i'd love
those texas hats i don't know if we get
away with it in washington that's why
but i love him then trump really
struggling to say the word
statistics telling you within a very
short period of time you're going to see
some statistics coming out on one
statistics i got to do it right
otherwise they'll say what's wrong
i like that statistics so this is
already
bad enough right this is colorado
springs but then we go to las vegas and
things get even worse
trump trying to talk about some health
care plan he was supposedly going to do
already
but then it never happened and he sounds
like a used car
salesman notice that trump in vegas this
is now
downer trump trump in colorado springs
was upper trump red
talking quickly this is now donald trump
talking about
we're gonna give you brand new
pre-existing now you might be saying
there's got to be some other word
missing there
yeah but trump's talking about brand new
pre-existing
for obamacare but we're going to
terminate it
we're going to give you your
pre-existing 100 otherwise i won't do it
we're going to give you brand new
pre-existing and we're going to have a
great health care that's much less
expensive
then trump mocks joe biden for his
stutter that's a disability
it's like mocking someone for having
diabetes
and biden is angry biden is angry
everything's anger cheesy
and that's what happens when you can't
get the words out
no it does that's what happens right
when you can't get the words out you get
angry
you get angry because you can't get the
words that might happen to me someday
can you imagine if that happened to me
man would i be a bad guy
and then this is the height of
megalomania
trump claims and maybe believes that if
a plane crashed with 700 people on it
media wouldn't cover it but instead they
would talk about
donald trump you know cable was supposed
to be obsolete
and now they're doing the highest
numbers they've ever done if an airplane
goes down with 700 people they don't
cover it
if it's not trump related they don't
cover it it's got to be trump or trump
related
so the plane goes down and it's total
devastation
if a ship goes down if the titanic
if the titanic equivalent went down they
wouldn't cover it unless
i was on the sucker and then of course
the
capstone the slurring begins to take
place in vegas remember trump was
upper trump in colorado springs trump
downer trump
in vegas and downer trump often does the
slurring
ladies and gentlemen introducing
president alfred e nillman
but see nobody knows because you're all
too young nobody knows who alfred
it's bad magazine
it's very bad it's very bad and people
around donald trump are continuing to
privately sound the alarm and at this
rate if this continues
the debates are going to be something
else it will be like nothing we have
ever seen before
no matter who the democratic nominee
eventually is i
i presume that upper trump would be
better for the debates
than downer trump and so we would expect
more of the trump
that was in colorado springs than the
trump that was in las vegas nevada
let me know what you think i don't know
what to make of it at this point so
donald trump you have to see this donald
trump said during a strange press
conference
in india that uh he said a lot of
different things and i want to review
some of the highlights or maybe i would
call them the lowlights with you because
there's just so much here
and where i want to start is that donald
trump asserted
that two supreme court justices should
recuse themselves
from any case that in any way involves
donald trump or his administration it's
ruth bader ginsburg
because she didn't support him in 2016.
therefore
she should not be allowed to be part of
any decision
at the supreme court that has anything
to do with trump or his administration
and then sonia sotomayor should also
recuse herself
because of an inappropriate comment she
made which donald trump when asked about
this won't actually
cite or name this is a couple minutes of
video about 90 seconds
let's take a look at it together
[Music]
uh mr president you just addressed
coronavirus um
so i will put that aside for the moment
you tweeted about justice sotomayor
yesterday saying that she and justice
ginsburg should recuse themselves from
future cases dealing with the
administration
what is the basis for your opinion on
that
well it's very obvious i mean i always
thought that
frankly that justice ginsburg should do
it because she went
while during the campaign when i was
running i don't know who she was for
perhaps she was for hillary clinton
i can't believe it but she said some
things that were
obviously very inappropriate she later
sort of apologized i wouldn't say it was
an apology but she sort of apologized
and then justice sotomayor said what she
said yesterday you know very well what
she said yesterday it was a
big story and i just don't know how they
can not
recuse themselves or anything having to
do with trump or trump-related
uh the right thing to do is that now as
a supreme court justice is a different
standard
but at the same time i think it's a
higher standard in a certain sense
so they'll have to decide what to do but
her statement was so inappropriate
when you're a justice of the supreme
court and it's almost what she's trying
to do is take the people that do feel a
different way and get them
to vote the way that she would like them
to vote
i just thought it was so inappropriate
such a terrible statement for supreme
court justice
what was inappropriate about the
statement i'm i'm not an attorney so i
can't really look into it
well she seemed to criticize the white
house for running to the supreme court
at the drop of a hat to see
no i don't think that was it but i think
what she did say is she's trying to
shame
the way i look at he's trying to shame
people with perhaps a different view
so understand that on this basis
brett kavanaugh and neil gorsuch should
recuse themselves
from any case involving donald trump and
his administration
because trump selected them how could
they possibly
be unbiased interpreters of the law how
could they merely apply the law to the
facts
when they know that they are only there
because of donald trump if the case
has to do with trump or his
administration
they should recuse themselves as well
right and the point i'm trying to make
is that you can't have it both ways
either the personal opinions of judges
don't matter
they are simply conduits that apply the
law
to the situations and the facts that
come before them
or they are biased partisan actors
whose biases have to be sort of
monitored and babysat
and they must be pulled off of any case
where their personal lives
intertwine with the facts if it's the
former
then ruth bader ginsburg and sotomayor
are allowed of course to be on the court
when the cases relate to the trump
administration because gorsuch and
kavanaugh are allowed
if it's the latter then any justice
selected by trump
would be too biased to be in on a case
that involves the trump administration
in any way shape or form
it's illogical as are most things
involving donald trump
continuing on with the press conference
in india i got many emails from
people saying trump appears to be high
on something during this one
that's not unique sentiment i don't know
we don't know at this point what the guy
is on
trump at one point was asked about
harvey weinstein trump has partied with
harvey many times
but when asked about the weinstein
guilty verdict which we'll discuss on
today's bonus show trump says
he was never a fan of harvey doesn't
like him and sorry for the poor audio so
some of these clips have very very
distorted audio i apologize the
dailymail.com
i was wondering do you think justice was
served in the harvey weinstein case
so i was never a fan of harvey weinstein
as you know in fact he said he was going
to work hard to defeat me
in the election how did that work out by
the way i'm trying to figure that out uh
he uh he was a person i didn't like that
i liked
uh i don't know too much about the case
because
between traveling and and being at
meetings almost
every hour of the day every minute of
the day i haven't been able to really
see too much of it
but i was just not a fan of his i knew
him a little bit not very well i knew
him because he was in new york
uh not not a person that i like i will
say the
the people that liked him were the
democrats
michelle obama loved him loved him so
definitely
downer trump at this press conference
doesn't like harvey weinstein then trump
got
into the phase of the press conference
during which he brags about
war crimes saying that we took oil and
gas
we took oil rather not oil and gas we
took oil
from syria and we have soldiers guarding
the oil
al qaeda last week you saw what happened
there so
nobody's done more than what i've done
and but at the same time
russia should do it iran should do it
iraq should do it
syria should do it you know we're in a
different part of the world we're doing
it everybody says you're the only ones
that can do it well
at some point these other countries i
mean iran should do it
iran hates isis and they should do it
and we've done a great job we've taken
our
soldiers essentially out of syria except
for little hot spots that we figured you
know we'll do
that develop but we've taken the oil
and the soldiers we have there are the
ones guarding the oil
we have the oil now understand that
every time
trump says we've taken the oil he might
be lying like it might just be another
trump lie but if it's true
it is considered a war crime if u.s
troops
or u.s corporations take oil from
syria without bashar al-assad's
permission
it is a war crime that is called
pillaging according to legal experts
because the land and its resources
doesn't belong to us
it belongs to syria now i don't like
assad
but if trump takes oil without assad's
okay that is pillaging
and pillaging is a war crime trump
regularly admitting if he's telling the
truth
to a war crime he might be lying though
then it gets really funny now i'll tell
you
i am concerned about coronavirus it's
serious we're now up to more than 80 000
cases that we know about
china may be hiding tens of thousands of
additional cases
2 700 deaths as of this morning 2707 was
the official death toll
as of this morning but trump is a
hypocrite on coronavirus
just like he's a hypocrite on most
things back in 2014
during the ebola scare which had a huge
political component and it evaporated
the day after the 2014
midterms it was used ebola was used as a
proxy to attack barack obama and in fact
trump did this tweeting back in 2014
quote
ebola patient will be brought to the u.s
in a few days
now i know for sure that our leaders are
incompetent
keep them out of here in all caps during
this press conference in india just
hours ago
donald trump hilariously had that tweet
read to him by a reporter
and was asked coronavirus patients are
coming to the united states
isn't this a double standard listen to
trump's answer again i apologize for the
audio breakup
some of these clips just something wrong
with the recording it's not on
our end and trump wildly claims that
back in 2014
no one had even heard of ebola which is
obviously untrue on corona virus
specifically mr president 2014
when the ebola situation was very
concerning to so many americans you
tweeted
ebola patient will be brought to the u.s
in a few days now i know for sure that
our leaders
are incompetent and all caps he wrote
keep them out of here
more than 20 americans have now been
brought back to the united states
with coronavirus by your own measure
does that mean
that your government has been
incompetent are you pleased with the
response
in case you don't know between ebola and
coronavirus
big big difference it's like day and
night and i felt that we should bring
them back their americans
we should bring them back with ebola uh
it was
it's very explosive it's very terrible
we're making tremendous rides on ebola
with
the things that we're doing as you know
isn't some of the money that you're
requesting
but there's a tremendous there's a vast
difference than in
around 14 14 or 12
and at that time nobody had ever even
heard of ebola or ever conceived of
something where you basically
people would disintegrate and uh
we're still working on ebola listen to
that no one had even heard of ebola in
2014.
what is he talking about these are the
sort of off-the-cuff rants of an
ignorant madman looking to justify his
own hypocritical behavior now the
reality is yes
ebola is different than coronavirus
ebola
has a higher death rate than coronavirus
but coronavirus is passed it's
transmitted
much more easily because coronavirus can
be passed through the air through
droplets sneezes coughs ebola spreads
only through direct contact so it's much
easier to transmit coronavirus than
ebola
i'm not suggesting that americans with
coronavirus not be allowed back into the
country
what i'm pointing out is trump's
hypocrisy and really the difference is
obama was president when it was ebola
trump is president now when it's
coronavirus that's really the only
difference
so another day another embarrassing
press conference for trump
as we showed you earlier the india trip
not going super well a massive
indian crowd of a hundred thousand
literally running to the exits crowding
the exits as donald trump spoke
yesterday
that video is hilarious the press
conference is disturbingly odd
another bad trip for donald trump
figuratively and literally depending on
your opinion of donald trump's
uh possible drug use bad trip takes on
another meaning
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman quick break
back after this i've been trying to uh
prepare myself
for this first segment because this is
some of the funniest stuff that i have
ever seen
uh donald trump went to india to hang
out
with indian prime minister narendra modi
who actually shares some policy ideas
with trump trump doesn't want to fund
dealing with climate change
modi cut the budget for dealing with the
environment by 50 percent
modi wants to privatize the economy on a
sort of neo-liberal framework the same
way that donald trump does
many similarities between the two
leaders so trump goes to india
and modi speaks and then trump speaks
before a massive crowd
embarrasses himself by mispronouncing so
much stuff
and there's video of the crowd literally
fleeing the stadium like the the exits
are packed it's as if
the patriots are up 40 in the fourth
quarter
and the place is clearing out to avoid
traffic
and the visual it's like a horror movie
it's like a disaster movie where
everyone is just running away
from donald trump's speech it's so
embarrassing
in every way and let's go through it
it started off really oddly with trump
walking out into the stadium to the tune
of the village people song
macho man it's already weird i'm not
going to play that segment
because i don't want to have copyright
issues today we had plenty yesterday
which i'll tell you about later
and check this out this now this is very
risky stuff to put on a teleprompter in
front of donald trump
the name swami vivekananda
that's risky and trump of course refers
to him
as kamun dun and it's
just as good as it sounds as the great
religious teacher
swami vivek
once said
that's a doozy i mean like why even put
that up on a prompter for trump right
it's just
uh relentlessly self-destructive
then trump mangles the names of two
indian
cricket stars tendulkar and kohli and
this is just
so entertaining where your people cheer
on some of the world's greatest qriket
players
from sun tendulkar
he also mispronounced vedas ancient
hindu religious
texts as vestas which is
something else altogether and then of
course the place
by the time trump was done speaking was
half empty or more because thousands
tens of thousands of people were running
for the
exits while donald trump was speaking
trump of course trying to sell it as you
know i had a crowd of a hundred thousand
and it's true at the outset it was very
very full
uh but the report from the bbc is that
as the speech went on
and trump was making a fool out of
himself people
started to get up and leave and you can
see in the video
uh a crowd formed at the exits people
could not
exit quickly enough and as you can see
if you're watching
the stadium ends up half empty while
donald trump is uh is talking
can you imagine the bbc reporting quote
crowds began leaving midway through the
u.s president's speech
let's now check out the video with the
audio and you will see that as donald
trump is speaking
the exits are crammed it's almost like
uh a bomb went off and everybody's
trying
it's like the place is on fire and
people are trying to get out of a
crowded theater
people barely able to squeeze out uh as
donald trump is speaking take a look
rich and poor young and old take pride
in the glories of your past
unite for an even brighter future and
let our two
nations always stand together as
powerful defenders of peace and liberty
and the hope
of a better world it's amazing just one
laughingstock after another it is
truly truly amazing stuff and
uh overall a very embarrassing trip for
the united states donald trump being in
india as is often the case i mean it's
often the case that when donald trump
travels abroad it's it's very
embarrassing for the united states and
this is one of the things that
you know it's going to take some time
once trump is gone there will be
relationships that have to be rebuilt
the the sort of um i don't i don't even
necessarily want to call it prestige but
the knowledge on the behalf of our our
allies
and counterparts geopolitical
counterparts they're not all allies
their knowledge that they are dealing
with a real diplomat
someone that can be trusted someone who
understands things
that's going to take some time to
rebuild a lot of those relationships and
the next thing i want to talk about
is the wacky press conference that
donald trump gave
i guess it would be sort of this morning
india time
uh during this trip let's talk about
that next it has been
a very long night and day
here at the david pakman show one
bleeding into the next
you have no idea what we've been dealing
with since about 9
p.m last night until very late
this morning i'm sort of in disbelief
that
this is going on but i am going to
report to you today
uh that our coverage of last night's
democratic presidential debate on cbs
was shut down mid-stream jeopardizing
our entire twitch account and the
revenue that comes with it
but the details here are what is
sickening
and this is way bigger than the david
pakman show the stream that we were
running yesterday of the debate with our
commentary and your participation
was cut either by high-priced
consultants hired by cv cbs
to shut down independent media or
by some kind of right-wing troll group
posing
as representatives of cbs now this may
sound confusing and it is
and i'm going to try to explain it to
you as clearly as i can
because so much of this information is
still developing we're in the middle of
an
investigation we're engaging lawyers
and as you can imagine this is not what
i want to be dealing with in the middle
of one of the most important elections
in our history
but this is how they win by making me
have to deal with this stuff
so sit down and get a load of this one
as many of you know we do our debate
coverage on twitch
where we've built a nice following of
close to thirty thousand viewers it's
not
eight hundred and ten thousand like we
have on youtube but we have a growing
and steady
base of close to thirty thousand
followers
on twitch yesterday during the debate
about halfway through our stream which
at the time had close to six
000 live viewers a nice debate for us we
had a lot of great audience
participation
it was a great alternative to the
disastrous moderation that was being
provided by cbs
our stream was shut down and i was
notified
that we had received a copyright strike
these copyright strikes do not expire on
twitch
and that means that we are now
permanently
one strike away from losing our twitch
account forever
the whole point of building up twitch
for the last eight months
was that the streaming on youtube had
become too risky
because youtube is already in the pocket
of so many of the large media companies
and they can shut us down anytime
at the press of a button so we started
building up an audience on twitch and it
became a nice source of revenue for us
so i get a message and it says you've
received a copyright takedown
for your stream of the cbs debate
now my initial assumption was of course
cbs
started striking people doing commentary
on the debate that they were
broadcasting but upon further inspection
it looks like my stream sam cedars
stream
the surfstream tri-hex's stream and a
whole bunch of others
they were taken down not by cbs
but by a shadowy organization called
praxis political legal if i look at the
email i received it says
it was actually praxis political legal
who took down my stream
on cbs's behalf now this is already very
odd
because a lot of the companies as large
as cbs they have an internal legal and
copyright team that handles this stuff
they don't hire someone else
but when they do they hire someone that
you would be able to sort of find
information about and that's where this
gets even weirder
praxis political legal lists a contact
email
in the copyright takedown that they sent
me that email is
legal praxis poll practice pol.com
so i immediately emailed that address to
see what's going on and to explain what
we were doing and that
you know we want to have this strike
removed the email address
does not exist praxis political legal
lists an email address where when you
email them
you get a bounce back that says address
not found
so now it's starting to get really weird
praxis political legal
files a copyright takedown for cbs their
contact email does not even exist
so then i said well let's find the
website for praxis political legal
when you go to their website they claim
to provide political consulting and
legal services
but they provide almost no information
whatsoever about who they are
and in fact they don't even have their
own website they use one of these cheap
single page placeholder websites by a
company called
card with two r's c-a-r-r-d
it's like a company that has a website
that is companyname.blogspot.com
very weird we aren't able to find any
real evidence that this company exists
at least under this name so we have two
possibilities here
and they're both really bad possibility
number one is
sometimes these hatchet job political
consultancies
they deliberately maintain almost no
internet presence
specifically because they focus on doing
things
that they don't necessarily want to be
known for like shutting down left-wing
streamers commenting on a debate
so it's possible that it's a real
company that
cbs really did hire them and that's
sick that if that's what's going on the
other possibility
is because cbs has not in the past shut
down independent media streams of
debates
and because companies the size of cbs
again often handle copyright stuff
internally
not by hiring out the other possibility
is that this company is not really
representing cbs
that they have fraudulently claimed to
twitch
to be representatives of cbs in order
to shut down streams like mine and so
many others on twitch
so either way this is a crisis
because first of all no corporation
should have a monopoly
on the platform that people can view
a debate that is being used to decide
who is going to represent
the democratic party in the general
election and who is going to be
president
ultimately if they are going to defeat
donald trump i've said it before
it's disgusting that one can monopolize
something that is in the public interest
or supposed to be anyway when the
moderation's good
uh like a debate it's disgusting but if
it turns
out that this is a fraudulent group
claiming to represent cbs and they're
just lying about who they are
then twitch has a real problem here the
contact email for this praxis political
doesn't even exist how did twitch even
set them up
as a an arbiter of copyright takes down
takedowns what they do
in order to shut streams like ours down
if indeed they are fakes
is falsely represent themselves to
twitch as
agents of cbs that's an issue if that's
the case that twitch needs to deal with
and youtube as well
needs to deal with immediately now in
the meantime we've had to obtain legal
representation because our twitch
account now is at risk
one more bogus claim and our entire
twitch account is shut down
forever okay so i hate that this is
what's going on but
i think we have to fight it with legal
services and that's not
cheap we could do the minimum which is
like i just don't do i need
more debate streams and they win maybe
we have to do that i don't want to do
that
okay but if we get one more strike on
twitch we're done like that's it our
account is done
for good or we can get really involved
fight it i want to do that
get a lawyer try to get these strikes
removed and figure out who is behind
this company
so grab a membership if this bothers you
if you believe that this is what we need
to be fighting against at a time that is
so crucial for our democracy
where we are trying to decide who is
going to fight against donald trump
disinformation propaganda all of this
stuff is happening
grab a membership at jointpakman.com
okay
um i i just i can't believe that
i spent the better part of the overnight
dealing with this
but it's where we are and we've got to
fight it so uh the coupon code 2020 now
i don't care if you discount your
membership or not we just
anything helps it does join pacman.com
you can sign up in under a minute
we're also on patreon patreon.com
david pakman show speaking to lawyers
again this afternoon
i will update you sometime later this
week
when donald trump is consistent on
something
he's consistently inconsistent and the
stock market
is a really good example of that you can
always count on donald trump to brag
about how
he's responsible for boosting the stock
market on days that the stock market is
up
you can also count on donald trump to
either ignore the stock market
altogether
or if he has to talk about it on a day
when the stock market is down
blame it on someone or something else
never him
the stock market is very down lately the
dow was down a thousand points on monday
900 or so points on tuesday down
a little more on wednesday and as of
this recording right now the dow is down
another 500 points today this brings me
no pleasure
at you you guys know i you know
republicans like to say
the left is cheering for a bad economy
despite trump
no no you should have seen me looking up
my mutual fund account last night
and uh it was bad it was really really
bad and
it's getting even uglier now so what
does donald trump do
he says oh yeah the stock market crashed
all week because of the democratic
debate
on tuesday night at 8 00 p.m eastern
time
hours after the stock market had already
closed on tuesday now remember
the market tumbled on monday but the
democratic debate was tuesday
night the market tumbled on tuesday but
the democratic debate was on tuesday
night
are trump's followers this stupid or is
he the one that's this dumb take a look
at this
thank you mr president you mentioned the
stock market earlier to go back to that
to be clear the dow jones dropped
more than 2 000 points this week are you
suggesting that that was overblown or
financial markets overreacting here
i think the financial markets are very
upset when they look at the
democrat candidate standing on that
stage making fools out of themselves and
they say if we ever have a president
like this
and there's always a possibility it's an
election you know who knows what happens
right i think we're going to win i think
we're going to win by a lot
but when they look at the statements
made by the people standing behind
standing behind those podiums i think
that has a huge effect yeah
isn't that just stunning that a
president can say this and that there is
not
complete repudiation of the obvious
absurdity of what donald trump is saying
stocks crashed monday
and a fox news guy named charles payne
blamed it on bernie
winning the nevada caucus on saturday
stocks crash monday and tuesday
and trump blames it on an event that
didn't happen until after that
after stocks had closed for trading
those two days
the democratic debate took place i don't
know who falls for this stuff but
somebody must
right because otherwise trump wouldn't
be able to get away with it and then
trump just keeps blaming other people
during yesterday's press conference goes
into talking about barack obama and
remember
this is a press conference as we will
later talk about about
coronavirus and trump is blaming
democrats for the stock market crash
caused by coronavirus and now goes into
talking about barack obama
what that is because he's kept interest
rates president obama
didn't have near the numbers and yet if
you look at what happened he was paying
zero
we're paying interest now it's more
conservative and frankly people that put
their money away are now getting a
return on their money as opposed to
not getting anything but i think you
know we're the
we're the greatest of them all we should
be paying the lowest interest rates and
when germany and other countries are
paying negative rates meaning they're
literally getting paid
when they put out money i mean they they
borrow money and they get paid
when it gets paid back whoever heard of
this before first
but we don't do that so i totally
disagree with our fed i think our fed
has made a terrible mistake
and it would have made a big difference
as good as we've done
even without the two thousand points and
we started off at sixteen thousand
and we'll be at twenty eight thousand
without we're going to crack thirty
thousand
uh we have had increases like nobody's
seen before
but we're doing well but we have to
watch uh
we're doing well anyway in other words
even despite the 2000 points it sounds
like a lot and it's a lot but it's not
it's very little compared to what we've
gone up
obama was bad our fed is bad even though
it's run by the person that he selected
to run it
everybody's terrible everything is to
blame except for donald trump who is
great and remember that
even before this 2000 plus point
stock market a tumble trump stock market
was
already underperforming barack obama's
those numbers are going to become
even more skewed in favor of barack
obama thanks to this crash
which i hate and take no pleasure in i
want to be really clear about that
because we don't play those games on
this show i'm not rooting for the stock
market to crash
i'm not rooting for the united states to
fail believe me ask
my girlfriend she knows what's going on
with my investments and this is
very very ugly no matter who is
president i don't want
our stock market to fail but blaming
bernie's win in nevada and the
democratic debate
and the fed give me a break is trump
some kind of time
traveler that things that happen after
the majority of the club crash
are to blame for the crash it's
horrifying that this
is considered an explanation from the
president of the united states or an
analysis
to many of donald trump's followers it
does not bode well for our country
that the president is even trying to say
this stuff
obviously why does no one just say in
the room
mr president the things you're naming
happened after
the crash not before how is it possible
that they are causally related it's like
saying a snowstorm that happened two
days
after a power outage is to blame for the
power outage
how is that possible how does that even
make any remote sense and of course
the bigger picture is that trump is part
of the market crash but it's really
larger fears of course about coronavirus
and we are not prepared to deal with it
here in the united states
i really want to dig in more to this we
had a lot of reaction to yesterday's
interview
with dr isaac bogash about coronavirus
and we have trump's press conference
from yesterday he's putting
mike pence in charge of coronavirus the
guy barely believes in science
so we'll talk about all of that coming
up for now let me know your thoughts on
trump's stock market explanation i'm on
twitter
at d pacman